et pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric jeanjean restaurateurs patron
de la brasserie des templiers à
marseille secrétaire général l'umih 13
bonsoir frédéric jeanjean merci d'être
avec nous jean jacques hazan bros qui
médecin hospitalier l'hôpital bichat
économiste de la santé à l'université
paris descartes bonsoir à vous aussi et
enfin alain houpert sénateur les
républicains de la côte-d'or bonsoir à
vous aussi
elle a offert merci d'être là je vais
commencer par la réaction du politique
que vous êtes
jean castex voilà qui appelle à la
responsabilité restrictions renforcées
notamment dans le couvre-feu un
couvre-feu les cinémas et la culture
attendront mais dans le même temps on
allège avec un déconfinement le 15
décembre vous l'avez trouvé comment jean
castex
j'ai trouvé comme à son habitude mais il
ya eu deux dents sort aujourd'hui il ya
eu l'expression du premier ministre du
ministre de la santé il ya eu aussi au
sénat la chambre haute
la sortie du rapport sur la gestion de
la crise fait sanitaires un rapport de 4
152 pages et j'ai essayer d'avaler cet
après midi une commission qui a écouté
133 personnes qui est ce rapport pointe
une politique de santé
guidés par la doctrine technocratique et
la logique médiateur au détriment des
patients qui devrait en être le centre
donc est ce rapport pointe de l'absence
d'anticipation de l'état qui repose sur
de mauvaises décisions
un vrai faux rapports une réécriture de
l'histoire et cela fait beaucoup pour un
gouvernement qui réclame la confiance
des français pour une stratégie
sanitaire
c'est à dire on va y revenir parce que
vous faites allusion effectivement
jérôme salomon notamment qui est le
directeur de l'agencé régionale
200 de la haute autorité de santé qui
est visé par ce rapport on va y revenir
aux sénateurs si vous le voulez bien
dans quelques instants mais j'aimerais
tout d'abord effectivement et ce à un
lien vous avez raison débriefer ce point
presse de jean castex
ça veut dire frédéric jeanjean que c'est
dans cette lignée de la mauvaise gestion
de la crise sanitaire par le
gouvernement ou le gouvernement prend
quand même les bonnes décisions selon
vous comment vous l'avez vous les avez
accueilli ces annonces ce soir écouter
jusqu'à maintenant ils se sont trompés
leurs prévisions ils se sont encore
retrouvés comme j'ai dis avec le nombre
de fois où il pleut ou il se plante et
où ils nous plantent je crois qu'au
printemps avoir des récoltes fantastique
parce que ça devient dramatique ça
devient dramatique parce que rappelez
vous la première phase de confinement
mais les masques on met pas les masques
la maintenance et on va ouvrir
finalement nous voit plus vous savez
nous qu'est ce qu'on a entendu ce soir
qu'on repoussée de trois semaines pour
les salles de spectacle mais on sait
très bien que nous derrière on a le
risque de d'avoir encore trois semaines
de plus
et puis vous savez ils disent qu'ils
accompagnent au maximum moi je cet après
midi je sais pas si vous pouvez passer
les images nous en sommes réduits nous
puisque nous en sommes troisièmes
confinement à faire une banque
alimentaire avec nos fournisseurs pour
pouvoir aider les chefs d'entreprises
qui n'ont plus les moyens de subvenir au
quotidien je distribue des pâtes de la
farine de l'huile des oeufs
on en est à ça et je vais vous dire non
c'est encore quelque chose
des gens qui sont complètement de passer
sous les radars c'est le portage
salarial
parce qu'ils n'ont pas droit au chômage
partiel et ils n'ont pas droit aux aides
en tant que chef d'entreprise et ils
n'ont en rien et beaucoup se trouvent
dans une difficulté et une détresse et
qui sont absolument indescriptible
donc en termes de gestion excusez moi
mais c'est c'est un zéro pointé vous
savez je suis chef d'entreprise
j'essaye d'anticiper j'essaye de prévoir
et là on nous apprend que
encore une fois les prévisions tout ce
qu'ils ont pu essayer d'envisager
d'autres voies mais ils se sont plantés
écoutez je crois que c'est entre les
mauvais écouter jean castex sur ce thème
puisque vous faisiez allusion à ces
aides
le premier ministre qui défend lui
plutôt son bilan le bilan du
gouvernement sur ce plan écouter pour
les commerces qui ont dû fermer en
novembre le formulaire d'accès aux aides
a été mis en ligne le 4 décembre et 372
1000 entreprises ont déjà touché les
versements pour un montant total de près
de 2 milliards d'euros
en ce moment ce sont encore 1 million
600 mille salariés qui bénéficient de
l'activité partielle notamment dans
l'hôtellerie la restauration ou encore
l'événementiel nous continuons à
améliorer et à compléter nos dispositifs
pour que personne ne soit laissé de côté
le fonds de solidarité pourra désormais
bénéficier aussi aux prestataires
exploitants agricoles travaillant avec
le secteur de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration ou aux sous traitants du
monde de l'événementiel notamment
sportifs et culturels
on va faire réagir dans quelques
instants évidemment le docteur en gros
ce qui est aussi sur la partie médicale
mais mais tout de même puisque vous avez
lancé le sujet en frédéric jeanjean sur
ces entreprises le premier ministre
défend son bilan c'est vrai qu'a eu un
chômage partiel important en france il
n'empêche qu'il ya beaucoup d'auto
entrepreneur de petits commerçants qui
risque tout simplement leur peau qui
rompt déjà d'ailleurs mis pour beaucoup
la clé sous la porte allain ou père
votre réaction sur ce point le bilan le
gouvernement comme un bon bilan en
matière des deux par rapport peut-être à
d'autres pays j'entends
l'autosatisfaction du gouvernement par
la parole du premier ministre mais
j'entends aussi la souffrance des petits
commerçants et en particulier des
restaurateurs ou parler de chômage
partiel mais chômage partiel il est
partial et concerne les salariés pas les
entrepreneurs et puis on a complètement
oublié le problème des congés payés
parce que quand vous êtes au chômage
partiel
l'employeur doit payer des congés payés
ça a pesé lourd dans la balance et les
aides ne sont pas significatives ne sont
pas assez importantes
les entrepreneurs dans la restauration
ce sont souvent des jeunes les jeunes
qui ont acheté le droit au bail et qui
payent des loyers souvent dans les
grandes villes ça raoni qu'e.on à
monsieur jeanjean de marseille et
marseille n'échappe pas à la règle de
toutes les métropoles
ces gens là avec les aides n'arrivent
même pas à payer leur loyer dont ils
font obligés de négocier avec leur
bailleur
c'est un drame c'est un drame important
on va voir bientôt dans les tribunaux de
commerce
dès que mais dès que deux pour de
pauvres des redressements judiciaires et
des faillites
et ça c'est grave parce que le plus gros
employeur en france c'est l'artisanat
n'oublions pas que le repas français a
été classé à l'unesco comme patrimoine
immatériel et le tourisme c'est quand
même la première industrie française qui
est sacrifié sur l'autel de la pandémie
a doctor ambrose qui quand vous écoutez
là frédéric jeanjean et le sénateur ou
père il ya toujours ces deux fronts qui
semble inexorablement s'affronter entre
la santé d'un côté et l'économie de
l'autre qui commence vraiment on le voit
faire
voilà des ravages je pense que il faut
pas se tromper
je suis professeur de politique et
d'économie de la santé je sais que le
sénateur ou père est également médecin
il faut pas se tromper
malheureusement et c'est dramatique le
monde de la restauration de l'hôtellerie
de la culture paient un tribut terrible
à cette pandémie chez nos voisins ça ne
va guère mieux à part ici ou là telle ou
telle exception comme c'est pas des
d'ailleurs bien pourquoi les stations de
sports d'hiver où les remontées
mécaniques fonctionnent chez nos voisins
suisses
mais si on regarde par exemple bilan
allemand la mortalité
le nombre de personnes hospitalisées il
est devenu le double de ce qu'il est
chez nous encore une fois il faut pas se
tromper
malheureusement cette pandémie peut-être
n'at-elle pas été bien gérée jeu
l'histoire le dira peut-être n'at-on pas
pris les bonnes mesures peut-être
effectivement à te manquer de masques
pour appliquer la politique qui aurait
été nécessaire et on voit que les seuls
pays qui n'ont pas été balayés par cette
pandémie dramatiques sont ceux où la
distanciation social le port du masque
dépistage etc ont été véritablement
assuré je ne parle pas de la chine et
des pays à un régime plus policiers que
le nôtre où la discipline est assuré
d'une manière que nous ne savons à
l'évidence pas faire chez nous
d'ailleurs que nous ne semble-t-il
supporterions pas les dieux point de vue
médical
la pandémie dont on pensait qu'elle
allait à régresser que les chiffres
allaient s'améliorer ne s'est pas
améliorée et sans prendre parti ni pour
les uns ni pour les autres et tout en
étant croyez le bien plus que ce leader
du drame que vivent les commerçants les
restaurateurs les hôteliers les gens qui
ont un bar un lieu de culture
les responsables de salles de spectacles
que ce soit paris à marseille ou dans
les beaucoup plus petites villes
c'est un drame mais malheureusement
l'épidémie est un drame
la pandémie est un drame au début on
pensait que certains ont dit c'est une
simple cryptée qui fera chaud ça va
passer ça n'est pas passé on a dit c'est
une simple grippe eh bien non et même si
il y à une mortalité relativement
limitée jeudi relativement et bien il se
trouve que les séquelles neurologiques
cardiologique que la maladie laisse y
compris chez des sujets jeunes de 40 ans
de 50 ans à peine sont absolument
redoutable et qu'on se rend compte que
on ne sait pas encore tout de ce virus
quant à ceux qui se lancent dans un
vaccin hasardeuse qui n'a pas encore
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
eh bien ce sont des aventuriers je prie
pour qu'ils aient eu raison
j'espère qu'ils auront eu raison mais
l'aveu par les docteurs et ignorant
qu'il faut être très humble on va on va
en parler si vous voulez bien de ce
vaccin on va rester sur ces mesures
vous parlez voilà de cette pandémie
malheureusement qui ne s'améliore pas
loin de là trois constats pour lesquels
nous n'avons pas atteint un objectif
selon olivier verront que l'on écoute
plusieurs observations peuvent être
réalisées d'abord nous n'atteindrons pas
les 5000 diagnostic par jour au 15
décembre
deuxième constat les conditions
climatiques vont évidemment durée
puisque l'hiver va progressivement
s'installe
troisième constat les vacances et les
fêtes de fin d'année vont augmenter de
manière importante nos contacts sociaux
le risque est donc si nous ne changeons
rien que la deuxième vague repartent
dans les prochaines semaines que les cas
graves se remettent à augmenter nous
l'avons déjà connu alors là on perd
c'est fait qu'ils sont en danger
évidemment on l'a vu aux états unis avec
une explosion des cas après fez being
alors on va pouvoir fêter noël mais
n'est pas nouvelle en vous êtes d'accord
avec sa préconisation du gouvernement
cette annonce en tout cas j'ai bien
entendu mon confrère le professeur de
médecine de politique de santé
moi je fais de la politique je suis
médecin il fait de la politique et c'est
important de pointer ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui on a mis le doigt où ça
faisait mal sur deux scandales celui de
monsieur salomon jérôme salomon qui a je
tiens à insister là-dessus optique qui
en octobre 2018 a choisi de ne pas
reconstituer les stocks de masques sans
en avertir la ministre agnès buzyn et
deuxième scandale entre 8 et là entre
guillemets c'est que monsieur vers en
affirmant que l'impréparation du pays
remonte à 2011
et aujourd'hui on a prouvé que
l'impréparation du pays remonte à
octobre 2018
nous avons été obligés le 15 juin 2020
d'acheter 3,9 milliards de masse dont
2,7 milliards en chine soit un coût de
2,8 milliards d'euros qui s'ajoutent aux
2 milliards pour les entreprises
nous sommes face à une catastrophe
sanitaire et je reçus et et un avenir
difficile et je rejoins le professeur
tout à l'heure sur les sur les vaccins
où il faut pas que les scientifiques se
transforme en apprenti sorcier et sur
une crise économique et sur une crise
sociale profonde
les gens n'en peuvent plus moi je vois
encore des patients
le travail à temps partiel je vois de
jour en jour se dégrader le moral des
français est moral des français moral
des personnes âgées qui ne vont pas voir
qu'ils vont pas voir leur leur famille
et je lisais dernièrement le livre de
d'erik orsenna son dernier livre où il
disait que la plus grande ronde de
l'histoire c'est d'interdire aux
personnes âgées qui sont à la fin de l'
envie de voir leur leurs proches pour
dire au revoir
nous sommes dans une crise qui dépasse
qui dépasse l'économie qui dépasse
sanitaire qui atteint le moral des
français est l'os le président de la
république a parlé de guerre et en en
réduisant les marges d'un de vos
médecins imaginer le général de gaulle
général de gaulle qui en quarante appels
à résister sans armes
frédéric jeanjean quand vous écoutez
alain houpert vous parler de la détresse
psychologique voilà de nombreux de nos
concitoyens vous vous imaginez vous
constatez au quotidien dans la banque
alimentaire quand vous avez créé tout à
fait là compagnon le laisser même
d'aller au delà
on a même mis en place des structures
pour la prévention du suicide parce
qu'on en arrive à ça
vous savez tout à l'heure on disait que
le 31 décembre pas lieu mais où
parce que quand on regarde les locations
de matériel de sonorisation il ya plus
rien de disponible pour le 31 décembre
aux skis espaces et on empêche pas la
réelle les gens de vivre
donc ils vont arriver ils vont partir
ils vont s'installer dans une maison
pendant deux jours ils vont me faire le
31 décembre et il ya plus de sono il ya
plus d'éclairage ya plus de pendant que
dans mes établissements ou des
restaurants par exemple on pourrait
faire un repas avec des gestes barrières
protocole sanitaire dans des
établissements où on fait attention mon
ami en place toutes les procédures et je
comprends bien que ce problème de la
contamination
mais au moins c'était quand même
beaucoup plus contrôlés que ceux qu'on
va avoir
c'est à dire des gens qui vont se
retrouver ils vont participer à circuler
dans la journée
ils vont arriver à deux heures de
l'après-midi ils vont faire la fête
pendant deux jours
et puis ils vont sortir de là avec
l'alcool avec les stupéfiants qui
circulent
à tour de bras en ce moment et ça va
être du grand n'importe quoi voilà alors
on rajoute ça à l'impréparation qu'on a
vu au premier confinement qu'on a vu à
l'heure actuelle vous savez moi je peux
vous en parler
le premier ministre se félicite des
aides qui arrive je dirais enfin on nous
les a annoncé nous nous avons dans son
troisième confinement à marseille on
nous avait annoncé des aides quand on
nous a fermé seul septembre début
octobre qui devait arriver immédiatement
les a touché fin novembre mois mais
pendant deux mois il a fallu surface
avec un effondrement de l'activité parce
qu'on avait des couvre-feux parce qu'on
avait tous ces problèmes là il faut
payer des lois on nous avait annoncé les
banques qui a cessé ses sept se sont
arrivés on va on va donner pardonnez moi
parce que vous êtes 3 c'est vrai qu'il
faut distribuer la parole équitablement
jacquin nombreuses quiconque vous
écouter frédéric jeanjean et sa détresse
et et nous parler un petit peu de ces
incohérences est vrai que là le premier
ministre nous annonce que finalement on
va les cinémas les théâtres et les
musées ne rouleront pas le 15 décembre
ils sont restés ils resteront fermés
encore trois semaines et pourtant il
avait mis en place un protocole
sanitaires très strictes c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu rageant vous l'avez
dit oui ok c'est un virus on est tous
victimes mais il n'y a pas un peu quand
même d'incohérences et d'impréparation
c'est pas où on va vraiment je crois que
malheureusement le problème est très
difficile à régler pourquoi c'est pas le
fait d'être dans un restaurant où les
mesures ont été remarquablement prises
par les professionnels j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler avec plusieurs
organisations professionnelles autour de
lui et me h dont monsieur jeanjean est
le responsable à marseille avec
différents propriétaires de
l'établissement à paris qui appartenait
à 7 cette union des métiers et
industries de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration ce sont des grands
professionnels ils ont mis des
gestes-barrières en place le problème
qu'on craint et que les autorités
sanitaires redoutent c'est parce qu'il
peut passer dans un restaurant où les
gestes barrière existe ou la
distanciation existe ou où tout et tout
est organisé
c'est le fait de se concentrer de
circuler dans la rue et alors
effectivement l'autre incohérences dit y
en a à l'évidence à sont par exemple les
transports en commun qui à paris comme à
marseille sont certainement bon départ
ce que
les organisations de transport en commun
ou diviser par deux leurs offres mais
que les nombres de gens qui circulent
parce qu'on les encourage à aller
travailler et tout le monde ne
télétravail pas et bien s'entassent dans
le métro parisien
comme dans les bus comme j'imagine à
marseille là aussi dans les bus et les
tramways donc il ya effectivement des
incohérences et je pense que à un moment
donné les responsabilités seront établis
ce sera le rôle des politiques des
commissions d'enquêté des uns des autres
mais pour l'instant on a à faire face à
une urgence de santé non seulement on ne
peut pas faire face exagérément un trop
plein de patients dans le système
hospitalier
ça c'est vrai encore que j'entendais ce
matin un collègue dans mon propre
établissement hospitalier car tu pas
médecin qui a perdu la main et le
contact avec le malade tant s'en faut
moi non plus mais qui disait s'il le
fallait on pourrait ouvrir 150 lits
dédiés aux qu'ovide quitte à dédier les
a envoyé les malades des autres
pathologies dans d'autres établissements
qui eux seraient covit free c'est à dire
exempt de covile sans risque de
contamination à paris comme à marseille
comme à lyon comme dans les grandes
villes il ya plusieurs établissements
pourraient les répartir mieux que tout
ça soit des fautes de gestion des
différentes institutions
il sera temps de l'établir et encore une
fois je ne suis pas le responsable
politique le sénateur
j'ai seulement on va terminer à temps
dans les rainures jean sanitaires on
faire face à la maladie et aux formes
qui nécessite pas d'hospitalisation mais
qui laisse des dizaines de patients des
milliers de patients dans la détresse et
qui ont des séquelles graves
c'est ça le problème et on se payait le
luxe une troisième crise médicale
économique sociale sociétale et
politique en plus nous nous arrangerait
vraiment pas il ya qu'à voir ce qui se
passe chez nos voisins italiens ou
allemands aujourd'hui pourquoi parler
bref des britanniques qu'ils vaccinent
sur un vaccin non autorisée justement
joue les tatas transition le mot de la
fin pour alain houpert vous entendu
parler de ce rapport et on va d'ailleurs
y revenir longuement 21h sur cette mise
en cause de jérôme salomon et sur le
vaccin là on perd vous
espérer une meilleure gestion vous êtes
optimiste sur le choix qu'a fait la
france avec l'europe d'être peut-être
plus prudent contrairement au royaume
uni et de ne pas passer en procédure
d'urgence et d'attendre peut-être
l'année prochaine pour la vaccination ce
sera le mot de la fin rapidement je suis
inquiet parce que c'est l'europe qui
gère ça et quand on a vu la gestion par
le ram des civils le 8 le 8 octobre
dernier on achète pour 2 milliards
d'euros
deux doses et puis trois jours après le
ms se dit que c'est pas raisonnable
parce que c'était ce produit est
dangereux
donc si l'europe nous met dans la même
dans la même position ça va être
difficile à gérer mais je voudrais
revenir sur le restaurateur faut pas
oublier que les restaurateurs ont fait
des dépenses extraordinaires des
fortunes pour mettre en place les gestes
barrières et que ceux des dépenses les
ont encore fragilisé et pour les vaccins
on va utiliser un vaccin arn messager je
ne suis pas un grand épidémiologistes
quoi que ce soit mais j'ai quand même
fait quelques études de médecine et
c'est un peu une thérapie génique qu'on
n'a pas encore utilisé sur le mode daksi
nal et je pense qu un vaccin
j'étais présent avec ça on mettait même
un médicament dix années de recul 1
et là on a en fait confiance aux
communiqués de presse de laboratoire on
n'a aucune donnée données sources ce
qu'on n'a aucune aucune donnée donc je
pense que le sait le deus makina des
gouvernements il n'y a pas que le nôtre
pour rassurer la population mais la
population elle se rappelle un elle est
éclairée
ouais merci beaucoup en tout cas alain
houpert jean jacques hazan bros qui est
frédéric jeanjean d'avoir été avec nous
après donc ce point presse de jean
castex persie à tous les trois